All right.
I think that's it.
Oh, I want to try.
I think I can do it.
I will try.
No.
I think I can do it.
All right.
Okay.
Let me try.
God, I'm fucking so nervous.
Can I have you?
You have to stay away.
I think it's working.
Okay.
It's working.
Hi.
Can you hear me?
Welcome.
Welcome to my life.
I think I can do it.
I want to.
I have my world going on.
To show you.
At least now that you're done.
I know I do.
I love you too.
So.
I wish that.
The ears might be the wrong way.
This is a very high possibility.
Just because it's quiet.
Oh, no.
Why?
It's not better.
Does it feel too quiet?
Oh, no.
Much better.
Did you get your nails on the color of your yukata?
No.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Where did you get this key?
Do you mean this one right here?
Or this one?
It's still too low?
Hold on.
Okay.
I don't know.
How is that?
I have a link in the description.
Everyone's doing my job.
Okay.
This is my cello.
You like it?
I don't know.
So.
If you can hear my cat going ape shit,
it's because I gave Gimli a new toy with a bail on it.
So if you hear a bail in the background,
that's Gimli.
Nice and airy.
You like it?
It's currently your own box.
With a nice soft blanket on top.
And it's like a little
tingling platform.
I can put my nails all over it.
Are we in the box?
No, you're on a box.
And have like other sort in the tool.
Got my latex gloves.
Got a brush.
Got a little wooden stick.
I've got everything to tingle with.
And you just have a thing.
Looks like a...
Here we touch this thing.
What's in the box?
Yeah.
This is just a nice cosy string game
showing you
some more stuff.
This is a microphone.
Leave it more Gimli in the background.
This microphone
is $500.
So you
is
dollars.
Did you hear Gimli there?
She's got absolutely
nuts right now.
She woke me up
to
have to give her a toy.
Yes, this maker is $500.
And the other microphone
I use is $2,000.
And then the microphone
I'm getting on my birthday, my one year
anniversary for Strony
is $10,000.
Oh actually, I think it's like
$12,000 US dollars.
So that'll be an interesting purchase.
But
as my reward for
streaming every day for a year
I'm gonna buy
the K100 for myself.
And then we're gonna have
lots of fun ASMR.
Because apparently if I like
touch over the head
or hear me touch over
and I wanna do a video
putting my feet on the face of the microphone
just over and over again
and touch
my feet.
So my feet are gonna be like this
all over the head
of the microphone.
Your feet are cooking.
There's some balls in my
Okay, it'll be for
first order of business
is to drink my
motherfucking turn.
And gripper.
Some people like glass
touching ASMR.
Just generally
stripping over the ear.
I always say
it can be really cheap if you want it to be.
It doesn't have to be. These are makeup brushes.
I'm so confused as to
your feet and your head. I'm so sorry.
Knees to the side. I'm
crisscross applesauce. These are my knee.
This is my knee.
It would be better if I like
hug the box with my legs.
Would that make more sense?
I'm not.
This is my ASMR sale.
Does that make sense?
It's Frodo back and still here.
He absolutely is. Would you like to see Bilbo?
Are you ready?
Hold on.
I have to very carefully do this.
I'm not tilting it.
I have Lego.
And look, there's Gandalf.
So Gandalf is full size.
Turns out the hobbits are wee.
Okay, I got my Lego left of the room.
We can pretend to do ASMR on it.
I need to be very careful
if it looses.
You can fall apart very quickly.
There's actually one ASMR tingle
that I don't do a lot
and I really, really like it.
It's not glass touching.
I wouldn't put these to the side.
So this is called ear cupping.
Okay.
This is ear tapping.
This is ear, like,
I don't know, swirling.
Okay.
Like, I don't know, swirling,
if you want.
You know what tingle I like?
I call it ear squishing
and I go like this.
So I do with this umbrella.
Thank you for the man-bush.
That's the little
baby clicker.
I think these smart doesn't have to be expensive.
This is literally just a razor holder.
They're like, holding it.
And it's just the gentle click noise.
I think it's nice.
The ear sound has switched up.
I don't know how to change that.
It's the wrong side.
Hold on.
I might be able to figure out how to change that.
Give me one moment.
I think I can do it now.
Hello.
Please ignore the earthquake
that just ensued.
Is it the correct side?
No.
The sound was coming from the right ear.
Did you just make me change that
for no reason?
No, it's the good side.
Perfect.
No, it's facing
as reverse.
What? Wait, let's say this is the first video.
You're trolling me.
I'm being trolled.
Give me a moment.
Give me a second.
You can watch me.
Make the ear the model.
Chat is confused by the left and right.
Chat and me mix the stream way.
Your other way.
Oops.
Can you give it away early?
You want one?
It's covered in spit.
Did it work?
No.
You don't like it?
Can I lick a finger?
No.
That's me.
So...
I like those ears.
You want your ASMR really?
This is...
This is just your regular run of the mill
corp
C-O-R-K
But if you have fake nails
these nails are called SMS
and actually they produce
such a nice
deep
sand
nice deep sand
like that
which I think is really
What happened to your real nails?
They're now hidden under the
Do you have a breath somewhere?
I don't know what that is.
Thank you basically
but this
deep sand
is similar
to white noise
in my opinion
I don't know if I could
put it on your ear maybe
just pat very gently
a cup holder
I'm a very big fan of this
I'm going to be making a lot of ASMRs
with this in the future
because I thoroughly, thoroughly enjoy it
I'm going to record more of this as well
It really gives you a swirly
Isn't it acoustic?
Yeah. Why is my PC so far?
I don't know
I'm big over
Thank you for the extended membership
Hello
I also got
like a little fidget toy
We're going to
find that she's clicker training
We're going to find out what it does together
This is an analog stick
Like that
Last video, thanks for the extended membership
It's like this little
side-by-side clicker that doesn't click
It doesn't click
It doesn't have drift on it
This one's just a circular
little circle
Thank you Blackwatch
for the extended membership
Then this one
is like buttons
I can't do it because of my nails
I can't do it
It's so hard
This is like a wee ball thing
I don't really know what that looks like
I'm not very satisfied
Then that's just the bottom
Playing with an analog stick
a little
left-right-left-right
It's a PS6 controller
Can you imagine you made a controller that small
and you were like
Rendered thing
Thank you for the extended membership
That was like a fidget toy
It's not really for me
It's a baby kick
This is glass ASMR
I did it a little bit earlier
The problem
with glass ASMR
is that it's bloody
creating ASMR sound
Thank you so much for the extended membership
When you record it live
you can edit
if it gets too loud
Whereas if I'm quiet
and I tap a bit loud
I can edit it out close production
Can't whisper
Thank you for the extended membership
I am starring as a poacher
and the feet is just eating moist sound
Just jump
Can do it fast
See if you do it fast
That doesn't sound as nice
If I just very quickly go
That's not an axe
You can just take your time
It's not a ray
It's just nice
You can even see
the bulb is passing on
and then just reset them
by putting them back up
Is this supposed to be a tutorial?
I guess it's just to show you how the tangles are done
because if you don't watch
in real life ASMR creators
you only just
hear
you don't see how it's done
real close to your ear
or you can do it one more time
Now
this one is very hard to do
live
and I don't like doing it through live
because
the wood sounds nice when it clacks together
a lot of them
Oh, Chunky Boots
I was supposed to be working on this tangles
but your voice is so good
even when you're billion
if I was billion year
I'd be sitting on you
I don't think I won't sit on you
I'll do it
I'll do it right now
The wooden sticks
they sound good
pre-recorded and edited
and loaded
but sometimes
when they work together
you can make an unpleasant sound
which I'm not the biggest fan of
I can edit it
please do it
fabled fun
can't you do feet count notes
already did my feet, did you miss them
feet cupping ASMR
when other VTubers
do not provide
remember me
when you have to beg
and plead for a hint of anything
from another VTuber
remember me
you get what you want when you want
you get the delivered fresh halt
right off the oven
I'm gonna drink my tea
give me one more
that's how much I drank
I don't have anything I can give you
but I'll just beg
fresh, hot and fresh
when others make you
give you a doughnut on Milestone
I've already done it
I've been there, done it
get out of here
you're not a good boy
I'll need to hold up the microphone
one second
be ready
you've been sucked
a good boy
there you go
where are these
do you see me now
come back up
why are you so moved up
can you tell me what I'm about
hey gen mates
why are you so far up
microphone needs to be in the center of attention
shriveling
these are very good for
here
if you ever want to do realistic here
don't know if you can see that
they look much better
these are really good just for
a casual but faster tapping
so you know if you tap
I get some more fast
like you can tell that's fast
that's more energetic
you might wake you up a bit
but if you take something like this
although the noise is quite constant
and fast and general
this kind of sounds much more controlled
or do you want much more
if you want to be lazy
you could just brush it
at random intervals
the good thing
about anything plastic
is when you have these fake nails
the plastic
always sounds so good
I think of a plastic
on fake nails
like this
if you really want to tease
just one tap at a time
so you have to wait for the time
you have to be good
you know how to be patient don't you
yeah
speaking of being patient
let me try my teeth
your very beautiful hands
yeah I think they look quite cute
wrapped around things you know
wrapped around this comb
wrapped around
ice gloves
I think they just look really nice
wrapped around something
a brush
I'll rub one ear while I drink it
okay
halfway done
almost done
safe look I'm drinking
let me see those thighs
I'm making a cane to see them
I think it's like tea by the box
that's as best as I could do
why does your tea look like coffee
I didn't actually put a lot of milk in it today
so I'm glad you know
all the fingernails mommy can't wait
till they lose their marks
could you imagine that
thank you for the word
I mean I could
maybe you can imagine
while I do it to the box
through the nail marks
I'm gonna brush them away
I can brush them away
I'm gonna grab one again
almost done
okay and one more for good measure
cause we're such a good player
if it ain't hard and it ain't work
do you want to actually lay back
you're a real black girl
I'm gonna give you back scratches
nice back scratch
are you reading the elements at the end
yes I will read at the end
I'll try to keep up
but I'm crying
scratch marks looks like they hurt too much
are you sure you wouldn't let me
with my nails
well just cause they're pointy
come on
let me do it pretty
promise I'll make it
only cause you asked the knife for
yeah the pointy
I get a nail shoot
that's called
stilettos
which is the pointiest nail shoot
you can get
okay time to put you in the coffin
are you ready
these are just earmuffs
and yes they look a bit silly
and that's it
yeah
scratch your nail over my body
don't make fun
this is just literally regular earmuffs
I can do one at a time
so
put them on
earmuffs
very fluffy
and then on a wheelchair
you'll be able to see them
I can run my fingers
along the head and
and you'll hear
way stronger than I do
like a real stone
maybe especially from the inside
but because
both of the
earmuffs are on you
you can
when I can visualize it
you can also take my nail
and just
use your tongue
and you might think
that one ear
has more
fingers than the other
and that's perfectly normal
it is very natural to have one ear that is
stronger
than the other
you'll always be teaching
to look so cute
I say stop hating
I say go up there
they're actually
not to be an ace
thematus but they're actually really good
material to tap on
like
I know you can hear that
they're so good to tap on
for ages and more purposes
that was the earmuffs
oh I didn't do much
of this
so you can
to
hear
show you how much you can
I'm so sorry I might trample over
A.C. right now
I'm so sorry
forgive me
okay
I'm getting out
put it in
give me a me
give me mercy
give me an ace
give me a sir
there we go
tapping the family
gone right
so this just wouldn't
notice I
like to edit and post
because they are a bit
loaded and I don't understand that
but
depending
if I can have a steady hand
or if you don't have a steady hand
you might think don't use more
a bit more difficult images
because you need to be a bit
like not to be dramatic
but you need to be
a little bit precise
and what's going on
I mean I can really show you
this is what I'm doing
getting closer to your ear
if it works with anything
I try to go
around
so that little bit inside
that's the microphone
do not touch this
but they're going around
like this
so an ex-alcoholic
doesn't got a chance right
I mean I don't get it
but
I never like
put anything to this part
that's too much for the microphone
where's my one
how to
this is a perfect example
this is like the only tool
that I like close to that microphone
because if I twirl
I might look pretty
nice
I think it's quite nice
I'll just show it
I'm just gently twirling
you can hear the difference
when I go around
the earlobe area
that's going like around it
and then
as I get closer
to the inner part
I would definitely slow down
and just twirl
gently
there's no rush
there's no range
but this is just
they're called Japanese ear cleaning tool
they were
the best ever tingle purchase
I would argue
I'd say this was first place
for ASMR items
that I bought
these second place
the earlobes I never realized
how bloody good they would sound
and they just sound so terrible
I absolutely adore them
like I really do
and for other types of
ASMR tingles
let me just
get you ready for your exam
sir
I'll do both then
now
latex
adds another layer
an ironic layer
to the tingle
if you use latex
so
you know what your cupping sounds like
but this is what it sounds like
they add an almost crinkly layer
just something extra to the tingle
which is quite nice
but having another
latex thing
we'll see how it's going to sound
a little crunchier
like if I tried to tap
see how it's more subdued
it's deeper
I think it's good for me
can I
that's good
she we're the best to tap on right now
so like even though
like if we
want to do finger fluttering as well
it doesn't mean
well it doesn't mean
we're not that kind of agency
oh too much must wear gloves
shut up
but because you can hear the sound
of the latex moving
all stadoos
all these
tingles
there's something
I feel like I'm going to sleep
but I need to learn something
honestly the best info
I can give is
does it sound good to you?
yes or no
and if the answer is no
I don't know
literally
there's so many tingles that people like
that the majority like
and I'm like I don't even like that
I don't know
and you can always do
what's called
a distraction tingle
so like
so you see how like you would focus on my hand
right now because I'm
oh shit
well sorry
there goes the relaxing atmosphere
sorry
I can do what's called a distraction tingle
which is like put it in front of you
but then secretly
I'll have this like
just ready to go
so you focus on that
and then I go into just any sound
sure was distracting
well it fucking got you didn't it
or you can do some visual stuff as well
like I don't normally
obviously it's not necessary for like
what I do
because I do
but like you can do visual stuff
that's a bit silly
silly
hold on
oh that was really
anti-colonistic
I thought I was gonna go like bloop bloop bloop
no
okay it's not doing it
well I guess we could do it like right against
the ear visually
oh
hi hi
you're yapping you could do it
it's probably the funniest part
of doing ASMR
see how it doesn't
change how the depth
of the corks
so when you do role plays
for example
you want to be as realistic as possible with a role play
now realistic
and quotation marks
if I were to do a clinic role play
I'm not going to actually
get you to sit and do my exam
because I do audio on my base
ASMR
so doing things
as simple as okay
give me a moment, I'll put on the gloves
and then you hear the gloves when you put on
the ear
you can hear me use the ear cleaning tool
but when I read
the tool
you can hear the latex
and then I'll say something
along the lines of
oh just hold your head still
I'm just gonna hold you still here right then
so then you're still engaged
this ear for tingles
and you can almost hear that cupping effect
so you should be able to hear it
but so just hold still
for me
and
for the ear kind of thing
and you can hear the latex
you can hear the brush
and you can hear that kind of facility role play
and
I think it works out quite well
and it's like oh well
unfortunately I don't think I've
you know done what I've started to do
but this would still look a little bit
way for me
and then that's when you can introduce
your new tingle
now it's not
impossible to write the pop
okay
it's not impossible
can you try heart rate sound
it'd be a very
inappropriate doctor's visit
but sure I'll give you my heart rate in a minute
um
what makes
a role play really nice for me
personally is someone who writes them
is when it makes
sense
like you come in with a sore ear
I'm gonna clean out your ears
I'm gonna use all these different assumptions
I'm gonna do a basic sound test
at the end
like I like that
it's hard
sometimes especially if you do role play
after role play after role play
to try
a cohesive story
because some of the stories is like
just nonsense
like I have a
new patch, new patch where I've been beaten up
coming out for 15,000
subscriber milestone
and it just looks
like I'm doing a very very done
I'm trying
can you hear this
it's a fine tone as well
and
I do love it
with all the lore premise
that's why I'm not
enjoying that too
but it does get rather difficult
because you know there's only so many times
you can visit your cleaning clinic
well no that's a lie
you could just
you've got the new pair
shut up
let's take these off
give me a little teens right now
and whisper hate behind
it's my
hand
oh my gosh
I like that
you like watching me take it off
yes
can't take it off
oh hand review
oh
yeah baby
tell
me
it's kind of my
my true sense
you can do it
what you want
it's not
a big issue
and you can always
combine tingles as well
I'm definitely
of the sort where I have to like
tingle over and over again
pretty names
yeah you like the color scheme too
I wonder if you like it
after I'm pregnant
why are only
the middle finger and thumb
that color
I don't know
I wonder what it means
are you planning on
getting me pregnant
hmm
I knew color scheme
you were already pregnant one
would be a shame
if you got me pregnant again
on my birthday
what do the colors mean
my birthday is October 10th
for no particular reason
oh I'll tell you one thing
that should be nice
doing two different triggers at once
if I
I don't have polydactyl
no it's not polydactyl
Draco, thank you for the friendly
those nips are turning brown
will be like oh no
Mainstay pink
I'm going out for a scratch bar
you can do two different
tingles at once
you must forgive me I do not have dexterity
in both hands
ambidexterity there we go
you were already pregnant
before
same birthday mother
we love Vivi ASMR
she's amazing
it would be funny
to have a pregnant audio
nine months before a new time comes
wouldn't it
that would be hilarious
I'm afraid I can't count
the numbers
they're pink
have you seen the color
of my skin
what other color would they be
I'm translucent
you can see the veins
you can literally see the veins
what color would I be
if I wasn't pink
please elaborate
I'm transparent sir
I will give you the hex code
if you'd like
so you can do
combination tingles
they're not my favorite
where's my pencil
this one's different
green maybe
I'm see-through
you could find a strong engine
where I'm covered in bruises
where I ride my bike I always get tons of bruises
so this is literally
just regular
regular, regular pencil
and you can do combo
and you can do a little love heart
oh it's upside down
let me do it this way for you
oh
and some people
enjoy
course ASMR
so this is course
some people
adore course ASMR
there's also crinkly
ASMR enjoyers
there's like white noise and deep sound
crinkly would go into like latex
crinkle
there's so
there's like
how would I call tapping ASMR
is clean
and quick ASMR
for me there's subcategories
I don't know if you would agree with me
that there's definitely subcategories of ASMR
but me I think so
like clean
tingles I would say
there's like the tapping
that some people would enjoy
but then moving
you could go like
tapping sounds deeper
that's clean
I like when an ASMR
she uses her hair for ASMR
it's too short
that's all the hair you get
that's all you get
I don't even know
if anyone can hear them
yeah
it's so good
long hair grows
I mean I'm going out again
it's been years
time I see her
but yes you can also
combine ASMR
with different
tingles
I enjoy tracing
like visual tracing
like just following
your
following my finger
people kind of like instructions
ASMR
just let
my finger go a little
spiral
and we get
my system
and just
a smile
a joy
your little kisses
with lovey-dovey
instructions
ten
no I'm fucking me
I'm fucking me
still
no
maybe
Shani doesn't have huge army twin tails
I have baby twin tails
I'm going with my hero
give me a chance
do I have any more ASMR tingles
I would just do
hold on I'm just grabbing
a few more tingles
I think there's another one
I think we'll have this
now as much as I love this one
it's got like these wee squidgy balls inside
the only thing is
this fabric like the thing it's made of
gets all sticky and covered in cat hair
so there's cat hair all over the place
wait what's wrong with the visual
what do you mean you don't like my pointy sharp nails
going into this ball like
object
why are you scared
don't be scared
why are you terrified
don't be terrified
I don't know
where is your motivation
my motivation lies
in the ink
I don't even make enough
oh there's a cat here
ok
grab a stick and twist
that's how I make that camera
a deep person
oh you guys know like that one
I just clear up
let me clear up
your ears with this
regular makeup pad
slime girl they use more
how do you
cut a fish scratch with that itch
man
cut a fish pinches and moves for you
and
it's funny as a slime girl
why do you hate me
I'm not a slime girl
I'm a girl that slimes
but I'm not a slime girl
do I
make myself clear
I brought over this hair band
but I don't think it's going to do that
kind of a deeper cat
can I even put it on your ears
oh you look like a pretty little princess
what might work
I have no idea what you hear right now
we're all a bit slime brained
I forgot she was touched at me
you make a slime
yeah
I feel bonito
7000 sub video
when soon
not just yet but very soon
7000 subscriber
milestone is coming soon
I have a collab
or two for
oh hi there
it sounds bouncy
7 million subscriber
I think I'll
just relax at 100k
I think I'll be satisfied
as long as it's not alien
slime at times
so you get me a little too much
sounds good
you like it
I'll keep going for you
if you like it
okay
I'll go for as long as you need
as long as you're having a good time
okay
yeah
I think we may
let's see which way
this is so much better
I'll see if I can get like
to keep it there
thank god
it's starting to voice
okay
I think I'll do like soft spoken
and remove that accent
at some time
please understand me
what else had
me sounding like this
yeah a bit of tingle
aren't you big man
so when you have the whole world
subscribed to you
what then
I'll make
video games
did you
slowly scratch the part
between the ears of the video
this bit
okay
like here
on the index finger
like that
I can cut diamonds on the top of that
that
I can do a bit of this
try
hold on
I'm trying to be gentle
it's pain
rarely anything
I mean I can do it harder
you want it harder
okay
there's a center of the ear break
you just scratch your ear
harder
you want it harder
okay I'll put this
on you and then I'll do it harder
you want to like
scratch with like that
you want it like that
go harder
thanks for the
also tingles
from your fan also
thank you
oh yeah you like that
did you with the ear
so it's pretty good
mixed two triggers
together
do this at the same time
am I coordinating this
no it has to be one handed
I can do one handed
just behind
regarding the
oh it's this
I don't know
is that
don't use the elastic
marriage stream lens
I can do that
I would have to go buy a white dress
so
the rim of the earmuffs is
don't apologize
can you
can you do just the
band of the earmuffs
what
I think I can go and make sure
of it there
got your little text
you're still having the issue
hmm
that one side
go
over your ears
that's the
you don't have a spare wedding dress
not when you go to church
or when you get a wheelchair
hmm
I wouldn't buy a wedding dress
no I just buy a white dress
and get like a body con dress
it hugs all of my curves
I call me the one
do you want to listen to my heartbeat
what
my ah thank you
what is
happening on the bands like this
don't know how low
those are
we can just
do-do-do-do
do-do-do
thank you
I see you shhh
quiet my child
okay time for you to hear my heart
but you have to go
under my hoodie in order to hear my heart
so surprise I actually
up and under
does it sound all muffled
because you're under the hoodie
I don't know if I can
distract you visually
you can't hear my heart
where's my heart
hold on
I can hear it quiet
I'm not fucking myself
how little who
I just put my boob in you
there we go
I just put my boob in your ear
it worked
we all needed to do
squish you a bit harder
hi
okay there we go
did you enjoy lying
on my chest
can't
gentle
my
my handy-dandy little
now you lying on my
oh my ears are
home taking me back
that's not gonna end your real age
now this is a very
clode
load load tapping
over there
alright
no
cute characters at the bone
thank you
these are my gen mates
we all stream together
under a good finisher
that one's me
there we go
unfortunately the ruler's in sent me
so you guys aren't gonna be very familiar
with the units of pleasure
don't think it's gonna be there
you like the name
yeah
centimedes the birdie
everyone says I got such a small hand
I measure it from bottom
6 centimedes
from the bottom
I wrap my little pinky
yeah
what does stony chibi look like
at witnessing a murder
no I'm hypnotizing you
look
see my eyes
see how it looks like spiral
I don't know if you can see it
I'm hypnotizing
you really got all the basic back to things
of that
6 centimedes this year
you know what else
the 6 centimedes
3 of these
what's on the back of the keychains
you're gonna shit yourself
are you ready for what's on the back of them
boom
it's just the back
of the design
what am I
is that a 30 centimede
well your hands are enormous
no it's 15 centimedes
you goober this is 15 centimedes
you thought my hands were like
over like how long
it's 15 centimedes
okay
I wrap my hands around the broken
you thought my hand was 30 centimedes
get out of here
I like your accent
I spawned with it
but we never even got to the best part
yeah
time to change you up
I would pretend to put it on
but it's a rather reflective surface
so I'll put this in half
you put me in a collier
so I'm putting you in
is that for walkies
yes you're a very special walkie
but
these
beautiful beautiful things
are ear cleaners
but you might notice that I've
put some of the fabric away on purpose
the reason
because this actually sounds better
the first thing that's been done
is ear cleaners
I believe you call them
Q-tips
these are Tesco's finest
they came all the way with me
and I can just
but it's the same deal
I can make this
touch the black
this doesn't sound very right
but the Q-tips
you have to be a bit quieter
and how do you call them
these are ear cleaners
you can be a bit louder
on the outer earlobe area
this really shouldn't affect
the recording quality
or anything like that
but if you go on the inside
gentle
and if you pull out
the threading
the cotton
you can actually just
spin it
no, it will not ever sound as good as the Japanese
ear cleaners
that's her
okay, I think that
okay, let's do the next
so
I can do two at a time
and you can purposefully
now you can either mimic each hand
and tell each hand to do the same thing
at the exact same time
which is possible
if you want to try
to sync up the audio
on both sides
or
just fully do different things
to make it sound
a bit more unique
like you can start at different
locations
maybe spin one
sometimes hearing the exact
same thing from the ear
isn't the best
the knot is tingly
and
you just need to
the ear cleaning
the Q-tips in particular
can be
they can sometimes let off
a bit of a rough noise
which isn't very pleasant
and it has to be edited
post recording
art especially is more
the knot is tingly
I remember I said knot
how dare you
I totally didn't look up at something
it just hangs without
yeah, it can be a bit scratchy
so you need to be careful
if you do live ASMR videos
you gotta be careful
but you can't tap on it
if you have multiple Q-tips
in a room
you can actually bend your finger
and
you can get rid of them
especially if you're recording
a visual video
so if you see this brush
you're only going to hear a brush
so then if I cheekily slip in a little
you can hear me
adjust the tool
you can hear my skin against it
you can hear my nails clacking
your brain might be surprised
and
I can offer you
a tingle
okay
we're recording now
I never said anything about
a new product
should I feel like something
alright, these ones today
we are playing with
cork ASMR
I'm just running
up
and
cork
over and over again
just tapping
with my nail
I can just tap
tap
and you'll let me
just touch
over here
in your ear
and
scratch your back
and let off
yeah
maybe even
right here
scratch
and tap
over here
all year long
here
for my victim
to my Scottish tank
for
this cork on your ear
scratch
no, I just told you
I don't care
about cork
I like when you're
a good boy
and expand
that all you have to do
is please
please
keep me happy
because when I'm happy
I reward you
to move
what do you do
and
you don't get rewarded
do you want to be rewarded
for not taking these of course
the best part
about the reward
and it would be such
a shame
if you missed
the
just one
say
I'd love to
talk to you
I would love to
and
some people like
this kind of retouch
I'll do a bit of a comfort
thank you for today's training
thank you
I wonder if I'm blindfolded
or if it would be more fun
if you turned us over
I still have you
hold on I've still got you
you're not abandoning me
just
if you
excuse me babies
can I make something for a refund
I'll put them right here
now if you're asking for
a handcam
ASMR
this is very hard
to orchestrate
having a refund
one thing
a gc
hmm
what have you been doing
I don't know
you saw me
you've been laying here
give me some head pads
for being such a good boy
so good
are you sure this hand
what else is tense
in the refund
than your arms maybe
is it tense
are you sure it's tense
tense
person should be fine
are you telling me
where else is tense
you saw me
you just stopped me
where it's so
okay
you remember
oh dear
oh you're gonna need some
special treatment aren't you
I heard I'll fix you
because I know I can fix you
now I know I'm supposed to
protect myself
from the patient
by wearing gloves
but since it's you
I can take these off
sorry my hands are sweaty
but because it's you
I'll make an exception
because I need to adapt
don't I
why are you looking for a doll
a doll's name
thank you
you're welcome
I know this isn't a correct protocol
for me
I'm willing to break company
if you look at that
there is
a little bit less tense
it's like a massage
it's like
it still has a nifty touch
because it's nifty
you
you mean hold your hand
and get in
you think you're born
you need to work
at something
do
you
I'm good at rubbing
at this pressure point
this little reform
it's an acupuncture
but he has very correct
anatomy
so I have to cover him
I have to cover you up
because you have a very accurate
part here
the vacancy
no
like 45
give me
you want to say hi to the reasons
look we're here
hi baby girl
she doesn't know what to do
because of the ASMR
baby girl
are you coming in or not
if not have a carry on out there
I'm trying to think of some
wait that's right
what should we do
obviously
the ASMR girls are going to have to come
so shebe's going to
can I have stuff that's in here
oh my gosh
okay so shebe's going to help
with your hands
Mary she's going to do
under your armpit
oh shit
I'm actually a little bit shy
okay
acu's going to claw the fuck out of your back
again we hate this
she doesn't like it when I'm doing
she doesn't like when I stream all the time
that's a zero
Amy will help your headache
and for no particular
reason
she's going to be great
she will
surrounded by cute girls
you will
let me just
everything is looking good
let me
remove the cuties
I'll leave me there
for no particular reason
just using the underwears
I'm going to get a nice little
you saved me
okay
I'm just
cause you can make a
really big mark if you have enough there
okay
that's the
that's the string
look at the
swabs of people
I should oil up my feet
like Amy did
I thoroughly enjoyed Amy's oiled up feet
I don't know
the smell
not the grippy socks
you never heard of hate from each other
the grippy socks before
you want to faint do
I'm so sorry
give me a sec at the door
for that
with her is her item
a lot of money
it's mine
we need a feet cam
here's my life string
I've already done that
but I'm open to doing more
for no particular reason
we should check out my monetization
string
you want to compare with him though
no
I don't think I can show my
button
I don't think I can show my collar
no I can
so you know how I've got that manicure
pedicure thing
it's still stuck on my feet
like it's not there
and then my feet don't look that very nice
from the bottom
I don't know if I could like oil them up
and make it look a bit nicer
wait for it
I was going to oil them up
maybe for a foot cam string
where's the crust
cause like I do have my oil
my coconut oil
this is the holy grail
it goes with me everywhere
do it now
I don't have a towel
what do you want me to get a towel
no I'll make it a milestone
fuck you
I'll make it a milestone so you better like and subscribe
cause
for 25,000 we're doing
something
the vangaba
that's what I like to call it
your feet look hot
from the underneath
I mean
they look hot or wrapped around your
gotta let them know
these clothes are on for 10% off
do not ask
who the vangaba is coming
for it is coming for the
I don't know
maybe
try
we have feet
ahead of us
do you have any tingle requests
or is there any particular tingle you want me to try again
are you just enjoying
the teasing nature
a tiny bit of smithing
I don't think they allow smithing
I'm so sorry
I don't know what to do
I'm waiting until my morning is up
before the morning
do your towel
ok so
one you go to an accountant
two
you have to tell them what you're doing
I'm entertaining industry
you love the nails
I'm glad you like them
I like the nails too
I feel very
thin and I'm actually tempted
to keep going with the nails
is it touch less restricted with ASMR
yes but the problem is none of my
gen mates can go on ASMR
not even my outfit is
appropriate for a twitch
I would literally get banned
on twitch if I streamed
on it
keep going with the nails
yeah you want more nails
honestly I just might
I really like them
but I would need to do more hand
you want mechanical
keyboard
oh did your feet get better
after pedicure
yeah I have nails
guess which one is
missing through my spokes
oh you can't see
guess which one doesn't have
a nail
right type number one
if you think this is the one without a nail
and then type number two
I'll be interested to see
oh I think you guys are ready
it's number one
what's this one
I do not have a nail
and then a mumbic
too but we can't learn
time
yeah
we heard a scratch from
no way
we can hear the fucking difference
between not having a nail
having a nail
what happened
a Vietnamese lady attacked me
and she stole my toenail
and I tipped her $20
and she started taking my toenail
so the Vietnamese lady that
knows the toenail
and that she was actually the
toenail
it's Julia
and that's pretty much the story
the feet animals has begun
the judge will soon score
a more unique feet
no
she often did often these
can I be the replacement
of my toenail
you want me to glue you to my feet
does it hurt
no there's no pain at all
actually now that it's fully healed
it feels better to
stub this
whole nail list foot
than it is to stub the one with the toenail
this one hurts
this one doesn't hurt
I officially am immune to stubbing my toenail
no I went to the
she's a shit ass for a man
I went to the doctor and the doctor was like
okay this is what you've got
here's your options and I was like
I didn't get back to streaming I don't have time for this
just take the damn thing
I was like I don't have time for this
I don't have time for this
I've got work to do
Gimli I can
hear you out there
sorry it's raining
which means Gimli looks
so more active
the tongue again
does my tongue keep coming out on my tracking
no don't
we in actual is more
oh I didn't know that my tracking's there
oh well obviously
I can't see it from this POV
did you hurt your thumb
no it's to cover up ugly
I was put in there and they give me all the confidence
in the world
I wonder if I could put it on
I do have all the micro stars
from Onan cats
I don't know if you can see that one
you can see that one
yeah cats are dangerous
like I have a scar on my boob
from picking up feral kitten
I don't know if I can take a photo
and show you
but I have a scar
because I picked up a feral kitten
and it got me cured
my fucking thing got me cured
okay
blue bird
yeah it's like right next to my boob
so nip nip
I feel like my visual remodels
are covering up way more than it was
like the stars
much before
you liked your thigh video
or the live stream
the thigh live stream did well
it's my second most watched live stream
after the hypnosis one
I need to write the script for the hypnosis one tomorrow
the live stream of the thigh can
yeah you like the part where I ripped my tights open
yeah baby
I can't
I'm afraid I can't
rip these
although I do have a stalking in here
here
do you want me to put this on
I have one stalking
I don't know where the other one went
I went to Mars
but I could put it on right now if you want
I'm not ripping it
before you ask because I don't know
where the heck the other stalking is
why only one
I've lost the other one
I have no idea where it went
I literally went to Mars
one singular stalking
proof that's me leggings
oh no I have to take off my sock
I can't believe it
sorry I stole it
I don't know
you can kind of see the pedicure
that's still on my big toe
do you see the shine on my big toe
don't go pedicure
how do I show you that
I've got a stalking on
that was your collar
you can just see one naked leg
and then the sock on it
that's what it looks like
that's the strength
there you go
boom
kiss it
I have
a smurf skin
that's the
I just don't want to hear so much about that
Shhh
Can I do that?
I'm facing the person who felt it through the steps
Shhh
You can do like
I don't know if you can hear that though
I don't hear that that much
I don't want to rip it, that's the only thing
I really do not want to rip this
I need to be gentle because my nails are so sharp
Oh you can hear it good
I do not want to rip it
This is the best hand chemistry knife
A little bit
I just only cured my Tango immunity
You're welcome
I can't do this, I have to put the light on
I have to put the light on
Don't be like
No don't look, I'm so bad
Don't look
You're scaring me
Hey you can really see my ankle
What the fuck, why does it protrude so much?
Are you okay?
Why does it protrude so much?
Does that hurt everyone's ankle?
That's normal
It sticks out
You leave my baby feet on
I dare you
It's normal
You're complex with my fucking ankle
I can't believe it
I love you
Where the heck is my
Oh my fucking toes, did you see them?
The pedicure isn't off yet
Did you see my toes? Be honest
No, you're not supposed to see them
Where the fuck did that song go?
Identify yourself right now
You saw it
They've still got the pedicure half on half off
So they don't want to do it
I can't believe that happened to them
It's because the pedicure is like half on half off
Can I even do it if I can?
I have to like straddle the box
Hold on
Can I just like
Let me to approach the podium
Really
And before you're like, what are you wearing?
Damn right
What's on there?
I'm having to squat on the box so I don't break it
I just want you to know
We're surrounded by diversity
I said I was a ghost
It shouldn't be a surprise that everything I wear is black
It smells so good here
We sailed a bit here
I can't believe it
You're a brightly colored cut off and she's actually a ghost
Ghost running is real
For real
Are you going to circumvent the eternal darkness?
I bet you're circumventing the larger ones
Ghost mummy model one
And a year of course, the like
If you want one
I don't know what kind of darkness I'm in
I don't know
In six months?
Wait, what happens in six months?
I'm pregnant?
You're to impregnate me in October
Cutting fish are excellent at changing color
The black is just because dark clothing is black
I wonder if she's going to go as brightly colored as she is
I'm going to get like a red
I get a red face when I'm recording
Which way?
Pregnancy stream one
Do you want me to buy a fake pregnancy family?
Because you know I'm crazy enough to do it
Of course the ghost scots are my one and only weakness
That's kind of me
Imagine having a ghost
Scotland and a smile
Wouldn't that be crazy?
Wow
Do it? You want me to buy a fucking Pregel Bailey?
Just stop some pillows on today
Ask a lot
I'd say do it if it's under 300 bucks
I'll go look up fake pregnancy coming
Put it on through and I'll add it
It doesn't use through and gets loads of figurines bought for her
Lego bought for her
Make sure you get one that for someone twice you're fine
I don't know if that means too much
Imagine buying the Bailey and having to explain to the experts
Some things that don't claim for tax deduction
Because it's just so, like, ridiculous
That I don't do it, I know I should but
We've got to do an ultrasound ASMR
To see if the babies are healthy
Okay
Just need the pillow
See if there's anything
See, I can't do it
I'll leave it back
Sorry, I just peaked the audio
Yeah, I can't think to figure out how to do that
Bye bye
This is probably the best thing to do in the world
What's peaking in my mouth?
This is the best I can do
I ain't not broke
Praying to meet me if I know what
No, no, no, no, no, no
Did you? No, if I do, if you know what to do
I can't do that anymore
No, you can't keep up
Well, I'm definitely peaking in my mouth
Bye bye crushing
No, maybe we shouldn't get the shit treated in the tax
So I'm gonna say that I could do anything with my hands
We'd end up getting
Just because I make gentle gestures with my hands
I've not trained you that much
Are you that trained?
I'm not doing like repetitive sort of gentle moves
This is enough
Like, what do you imagine it again?
What's that clicky thing?
What are you looking at?
Some of us are usually gentle
She says I should gently squeeze with the key
I mean, I can grip harder if you want
Do you deserve me being nice to you?
That's the thing
No, no, no, just go play hide and seek with me
We're doing real ASMR, by the way
It's so real
Can't play with me, it's so real
Need a cold shower
Please be nice when we kip with your hands
Like a fence kip with a fence
Do I deserve it if you want me to be mean?
I don't know
This is a pre-recorded stream
I can also do this
Looks like these plastic wrappers that are on me
Just run
I feel like my hair is like super new
What?
Real ASMR?
Not possible
I'm like capable of yapping and getting to me
It's pre-recorded just nice
That's what I should do
I don't know
Holy shit
Ma, thank you for the 50 gifted memberships
Holy fucking shit
I love you so much
Thank you
Congrats to those who caught up with your thing
Can you feel a little tingle there?
I'll tickle
And
Thank you again for the 50 gifted memberships
There
Because the thing is that the thing
squeezes through
That guy again
I have a master of touching
Can you do the ace of tapping?
Yeah, this is just the last
I like to imagine
It's your tool
And I'm just gently clawing
You should do ASMR every time
Yeah, you will do ASMR every single day
And I just
Never do anything
Well, never play with the key
It's nice to lose by the way
Thank you
Bullnature
You want to put some cookin' oil on the glass?
Could maybe do that
Yeah, I like that
I like that
I do ASMR
Tickle
I'm afraid we've opened our coats away
Peek and shells
What's a peek and shell?
Could you say Billy or something?
Bullur
Billy, you're such a Billy
Or do you like when a Billy you?
An annoy you, tangle you
Such a Billy
Some shells of a peek in that
Oh, okay
Your Billy likes seeing you tangle ASMR
I like seeing the faces in you
I like seeing your inability to talk
You just look at me with your eye
And you get so embarrassed to close them
As if that's gonna stop you
From continuing on to doing ASMR
And a bit of a Billy
Only because it's here, you know
Mm-hmm
Yeah, you found three
That's good
You peek and sound for a little bit more
That's okay
Thank you
Yeah
You peek in front of my eye contact phone
To real, that's the best part
But then
I'd get you to sit down in the chair
And I'd have all the tools laid out
And I'd just start gently
Maybe over your head here
Crouch your scalp
And then
It just watches your expression changes
A little lower again
I'm a little past right here
Bring there
And each time
Just keep talking
But I didn't notice their emotion
And it would just spur me on
To go further and further
And you'd hear it in my voice
About how happy I am
So you'd be like me to it
Even though your body's screaming at you
Why are you doing that?
You're crazy
Don't lie to me
I think that's how I would believe you
A little reason?
I don't want to believe you like that
We're all speechless right now
These are called ace globes
I'm not mean to you
I wouldn't do anything to you that you couldn't handle
You like that I push your limits
You like that I push your boundaries
You like every little thing I do for you
That is why
You'll let me
You really let a five foot three skull defeat you
Well
The incapacitated
You can't think for yourself
Just gonna let you do
Don't believe too hard
Why? What happens if I believe too hard?
Are you gonna be doing something embarrassing?
Have fun with it when you're done
I'll go back to scratching your back
I just get used to the nails
The first thing that's a little sore but it feels good after
You'll like to enjoy it
Shhh
So it's paid back for yesterday and maybe
The tongue did some glitching as cause I'm so far away from the little thing
You're like all the way over there
Shhh
Do your worst
Should I bring you down again?
When can I bring you back down?
It's paying for you to relax
Do you understand?
We need to do a real ASMR
To wrap it
What are we about to do?
Your nicotine patch? Put it back on quick
Okay, time to get you nice and relaxed again
Is that a foodie doll?
It's a carrot snack
But I don't do it
I know I believe in it too
It's just a very good atonement of corrective
Can I do it at some time?
Are you all ready for this?
Oh, I've coordinated enough
There you go
Even the doll has a bug
Are you ready to eat it?
Did the doll even have ears?
No, it didn't.
Well, they're transfer tingles.
Tattattattattattata
in the cat room
and then we're gonna bubble run your head
Let me run you in
I'm sorry for getting it
Can you confirm if there's a bullet or not?
You can see it over here
I'll give you a quick summary of this
Can you confirm if there's a bullet or not?
You can see it over here
Okay
Now you're gonna call me
It's okay, you don't have anything with that
I'm still gonna call you
Get me with you guys
I'm gonna call you
Okay
Now, unfortunately the mannequin's head's a little bit too small for the head
I'm not sure it's gonna work
It's a bit big
I'm gonna pull it to the side
Because I can pull off the head
What?
It's still a little bit too big
Can we hear again this part?
Yeah, if she doesn't get scared
She gets scared and she runs from here
There's no one
I'm gonna make sure she doesn't get scared
Can you tell me if there's an issue with her?
Why is there a need on the mannequin?
I'm gonna continue to face the mannequin
I'm gonna make sure she doesn't get scared
She looks in the room all the time
Which means
Yes, I'm still gonna remember
Just from now on
Can you tell me if there's an issue with her?
Is she still going?
Can you direct her to her?
Hello
I'm gonna redirect
Into a genuine kind
She's not doing anything else
She must be on her phone
I'm doing Twitter?
What's on Twitter?
Don't leave us, I'm not leaving
I've got more days to work and work
I don't know anything
There's more content
I don't know what you're into
Are you aware of these earmuffs?
No, I don't know, I don't read them
I have hair that goes over my ear
Oh, real bad
Sorry
Are we getting so barely hit sometimes?
Is this preparation?
I don't know
Is it preferential for tomorrow?
I'm not sure
I mean, good one will be a puppy
Okay
I don't know
You don't want to be my little puppy?
Can you look after me?
Give to me
You're getting lots of scratches
You're gonna be all mine
No
Okay
I'm gonna redirect you to shoes
I'm gonna have a membership room
If you give me five minutes, I'll make a copy
And then I will continue with some health care for you tomorrow
Where we look at some kind of health care
Let me think about if you hit me too
Thank you very much
Thank you, I'm glad I managed to focus the ones that I actually do, isn't it?
Love the stream
But I make sure I have to get my nails done, don't I?
Get my nails done, my nails cut off
And then I have to get my nails done
Okay, let me go redirect you to shoes
And as a special treat, you get feet cupping
Next, the nail color
I don't have a nail color yet
Let me do it for you
Enjoy some MLTG on your feet
Did you just see my face?
I feel like I'm back to the corner
Please ignore the shaping
The webcam is attached to the TV
To the desk
If you just give me five minutes
I will start off the membership room
So I'm just gonna redirect you to my genie
But as I've learned
She is a baby now
So turn your volume down
Are you pumping the table? No!
I'm clicking on it
I'll see you in five minutes
Thank everyone who likes and subscribes
And laughs again for the rest of the membership
Hope I didn't offend them
Thank you so much
I'll see you tomorrow
For more ASMR
And maybe there's more hunt
Count streams on the way
See you shortly
Bye